- [Dustin] Okay, we're live.
Good afternoon everybody,
Sunday afternoon.
Testing a new format of Tea with GaryVee.
I'm your host Gary Vaynerchuk.
This is like water with
GaryVee on a Sunday afternoon.
Pretty excited.
Got some questions lined
up from the audience,
also if you're watching on
YouTube, LinkedIn, Facebook
and Twitter live right now
please leave comments
let me know what you think of this format
and how it's coming across to you.
And comments about the show itself
and what you like.
A Big shout out,
I hope everybody's families
are healthy and secure.
Hope everybody is starting to process
and get settled into a new reality.
Hope everybody is
starting to find their way
and see their opportunities.
And be grateful and humble and
let's get into the show.
Right Dustin, I'm ready
for my first question.
Looking forward to it.
And here we go.
Hi.
Oh.
Your no audio.
Can't hear you.
Yup.
Dust, make sure you prep people on audio.
Nope.
Okay.
I'll keep yapping.
So everybody let's see
what's going on on Twitter.
If you don't know this
little fun fact about me,
Twitter is absolutely the place,
besides 212-931-5731.
Twitter is by far the place
where you get the most responses from me.
Hello.
Nope.
Um, and it is no question,
this is way we're doing a little test run
on Sunday afternoon.
Little impromptu test run.
New format.
And so I'm excited that,
that we're getting through
some of these glitches right now.
What's up?
- Oh, shit.
(laughing)
- How are you?
- Yo, what's up Gary?
How are you?
- Come on, what's your name?
- Leslie.
- Leslie, it's such a pleasure.
- Awesome, so,
my question to you is,
how do you stay in your lane
when you wanna try different things
but you don't necessarily
have enough knowledge on it?
Like what would you talk about
on all different platforms?
- The process of owning it.
- Okay.
- You know, people think
expert is the only way to go.
- Yay.
- And I think, documenting the journey
to becoming the expert
is actually potentially more fascinating.
I think--
- Oh yeah.
- You see where I'm going?
I think of 22 year old me, 24 year old me
of like learning wine
and learning marketing
in the (speakers audio fades out)
would have been fascinating content.
- So, when you say document
the journey of becoming,
'cause I've heard you say that
in one of the other videos--
- Yeah, let's talk about you.
What are you trying to get into?
- So, I (snickers)
it's a couple things.
I really want to learn how
to direct music videos.
- Okay.
- And, but I also, like
I did what you said,
create a podcast.
- Love it.
- And it's a visionaries tale, um,
I've been trying to get guests on there,
but with my dog, she's
not helping me record.
But my, like, I also love
getting to know people.
And their process behind their vision
and everything, you know.
And that's kind of what
the podcast is about, but--
- Couple things.
First of all, don't
sweat the dog situation.
If you're saying that the
dog is barking sometimes
or bothering you,
I actually think that makes
your podcast more charming.
- (laughing) Okay.
- That's some real shit Les.
I think people over--
- Okay.
- think production.
And under-think humanity.
- Yeah.
- I think, you know, think about--
- Hell yeah.
- You see where I'm going?
Think about the--
- I do.
- You know, Les, people
are starting to get
to know each other better,
'cause their, my moms curtains
are in the background.
Like, people like love like real shit.
- Okay.
- Don't listen.
People always have excuses.
You don't strike me as an excuse person,
but it's subconscious.
- No.
- The dog is not fucking you up.
- Yeah, it's not
and like I had all these
questions prepared.
And when I was trying to record like,
she was just growling at me,
messing with the laptop but,
hell yeah, I will just do it.
- Also, interviewing people
that have made music videos,
like you should DM 4000 people, right now.
- Yeah.
- Celebrities, influencers, taste makers,
athletes, rappers, culture, models, like
everybody's responding to
more DM's and more lives.
- They are, yeah.
I actually did DM people,
but I guess it's like,
and I don't wanna take up too much time.
- Go ahead.
- How exactly,
like who is the target?
'Cause I know you said start at the top
and then work your way down,
but for me it's like
I've been reaching out
to local videographers that
I want to get to know more of
but should you take the chance
and like Cole Bennett or Taj Stansberry.
- Of course,
'cause Cole's a good kid
and he might just be in lyrical lemonade
kind of mindset that moment.
- Yeah.
- Because there is no chance.
Like that was a very important moment.
Of course you should take this chance.
You should take the
chance to hit up Pharrell.
You know like, (speakers audio fades out),
like what's gonna happen?
Your feelings got hurt
that see your DM? - Yeah.
- You know?
The answer to that is, there is no chance.
You gotta reframe it.
- Yeah, definitely.
- You can't get a yes, if you don't ask.
- Yeah, and like
listening to your content,
I stopped necessarily caring about shit.
Like been posting my truth
and my authentic self
on Instagram and all platforms.
I lost a lot of followers,
but I have been engaging
more with other people
and I think that shit's sick,
so thank you Gary.
- You're welcome.
It's always depth over width.
I'd rather have 837
people who give a fuck,
than 8000 that don't.
- All right man.
Thank you so much dude, I appreciate it.
- Got you.
Right, Leslie coming in with heat.
That was a really good question.
Really good question!
All right mom.
Special delivery.
- Hi.
- Hey, Annalee.
- Thanks for being here
to answer my question,
but my question for you was,
I'm a product designer and I'm looking at
starting a business.
And I'm not sure if I
should separate my business
from my personal social
media accounts and my blog.
I'm not sure if people will be interested
in what I'm selling
or if it's gonna be bothersome to them.
- I think, I think, I think that--
So what is the--
So one more time,
your personal accounts.
What is the business gonna be?
- So I'm looking to get into
gift and novelty products.
- Love.
- And, that's my passion,
that's what I love.
- You're clearly gonna make an account,
social media accounts
for that business, right?
- Yeah.
- And then what I would do is,
I would spur out things about, um,
that, you know, in your personal profile,
but not make it all of the stuff.
So for example,
I'm putting out all sorts
of content all the time
to bring value,
and what I'm looking to do is,
is really try to, uh--
I'm sorry, I'm doing a private chat,
so I'm testing some new stuff.
Dustin, I thought I was
private chatting you,
but I'm private chatting Florella,
so that's kind of interesting,
so we need to figure that part out.
So Annalee, the thing
that you're gonna do,
is what I kinda do with WineText, right.
So I share my normal stuff
which is try to bring new
value in everybody else,
but once in a while,
for my dad's business,
I'll post something and
say, sign up for WineText.
You're gonna do the same thing.
You're gonna create an
account for the business
that occasionally on your own personal--
definitely on the first day.
Like, your gonna pound
all your personal accounts
and say, hey I've started
this new business,
it would mean the world to
me if you can check it out
and maybe even pick up
something if you're interested.
And then a week later, you're gonna say,
man this is tough doing this new thing,
here's my busnis--
You know, so, I think it's
3 to 30% of your content
for the first couple
of months of its launch
that will go really well.
- Okay, that's really helpful.
And then, one other questions is,
I have a blog that kind
of relates to the product
that I'm hoping to sell
and I'm just wondering
should I leverage the blog
and like have the the
product for sale on the blog,
or should I just completely
rebuild the website for that--
- One more time, I apologize.
I'm testing out a new platform
and I just realized that have a live chat.
Buttons, so Dennis Weber
and Stove and Gonzalo,
Henry Yu, I'm getting excited,
so I apologize Annalee.
One more time.
- No worries.
So my question for you was,
I have a blog that relates to kind of
gift and novelty and DIY,
and I thought I could use that as platform
to sell the product,
but I'm not sure if that's
the right avenue to go
or if I should just have
a completely new website for the product.
- You can definitely sell in that world,
'cause that's a very close correlation.
And again, it's about
jabs and right hooks.
The reason I wrote that book is that
you can give, give, give
and then once in a while you ask.
And there's nothing wrong
for asking with business.
What's wrong is manipulating
people into buying shit,
not asking after you've provided value.
And the other vulnerability that people
is when they ask
and most people don't sign up for it,
or buy it.
They get disappointed,
they have expectations.
They say I've had this blog for a year,
I've given you so much value
and why didn't any of
your fuckers buy my stuff?
And the reality is,
you can't have that expectation.
You're asking, you're not demanding.
So as long as you're comfortable
with politely asking,
and dealing with however many you get,
then you'll be superfine.
- Awesome.
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome Annalee.
Take care of yourself.
- You too, thank you.
- Comments are coming in.
I love this.
Cory Kimble.
- So you're able to see, like,
all these comments on the side.
- Yup.
- Good, awesome.
- Yeah, I can see 'em.
I can't do anything with them,
but I'm loving it
and it shows where it's
coming from, right, so.
- Yeah.
- And they, on YouTube, XYRBN on YouTube
HippiePicnic on Periscope.
This is great.
Paula Clark, what's good.
Let's go.
Burman Cameron, New Jersey.
Nicole, what's up.
Love this.
Big shout out to everybody.
There we go.
Oh no, Florella.
We're gonna keep working on it.
We're gonna help you.
We're gonna get you back on,
I promise.
We're gonna keep trying.
Joey, what's good?
- How's it going?
- Super well.
Where you from?
- I'm from Chicago area,
suburbs.
- Love it.
What's good man?
- Okay so,
over winter break--
- Yup.
- I got like really into TikTok.
And for like a month I grinded on it
and I actually like
I exploit a niche and
I gained a following.
And over like the past month
I got like upwards of like,
I got, I think I reached like 300 000,
which is awesome.
But then like recently,
kind of like out of nowhere,
it just like, I hit a plateau.
It was like going up
and then it just like stopped.
And started going down.
And so--
- It's happening to a lot of people,
you know why?
- Is it because the market's saturated?
That's what I figured.
- Brother, this is why I fucking yelling
like a motherfucker 18 months ago
of like go, go, go, go.
- Yeah.
- It's like real estate.
Let me give you the comp, Joey.
It's like a part of Chicago
suburb starts getting hot
and it goes from kinda
ghetto to going to rich area.
And you can buy up shit,
and the houses are 50 000 at first,
then when everybody
fuckin' figures it out,
all of a sudden miraculously
the houses are 450 000.
That's in money terms in real estate,
that's what happens with
attention on social networks.
- Yeah I figured,
'cause like all the kids
are coming back from college
and they're just scrolling
through social media all the time.
- And TikTok itself is
just exploding, bra.
- Yeah, that's true.
Yeah, so my original question was like,
I kinda like just stick
to my niche I guess
and so--
- Do you love your niche?
What is your niche?
- So... (scoffs)
My niche is, uh,
it's like an eight year old kid
figuring out stuff about the real world.
- Fuckin' love it.
- And so I like,
I dress up like an eight year old kid.
And then like, I kinda
made like a family--
- Do you wanna be an actor or comedian
when you get older?
Now, or whenever.
- I'm honestly not sure.
Like I'm a creative, musical type person,
but I honestly have no idea
what I'm gonna do with my life.
- That's a stupid creative concept.
I fuckin' love that.
- So yeah,
I'm like an eight year old
figuring out about the whole world.
And then like, I kinda
gradually expanded it
into like a niche about,
kinda like a family sitcom on TikTok.
But the problem is, is that
none of my videos are
getting on For You page
for like the last two or three weeks.
And I don't know whether I should,
switch it up a bit or I should just
keep putting out content.
- I would probably do both.
I would maintain that sitcom,
but I would become like Dave Chappelle.
Like the Dave Chappelle show,
like that's one of your things.
- Okay and then just.
Okay, that makes sense.
They do like a little thing
to kinda keep the audience going
and then keep it intact.
Okay, that makes sense.
- Right, 'cause no
create another character,
like the douchebag DJ
and do it like recurring character
and then create like literally,
literally, literally SNL the
shit out of your channel.
- Just make a ton of
characters, all that stuff.
Keep it going.
- If you had the creativity
to create the eight year old,
you probably have the
creativity for four or five
other things you know you can do.
That mixes it up,
it also makes us wait for it.
I see watching Living Color,
just waiting for Homey the Clown
and some weeks it wasn't on
and some weeks it was, so
I think that's where you
can find your creativity.
Including your sixth, you know
if you think about it,
it's the eight year old,
it's the DJ, it's the father,
it's the old lady character,
and then it's just actually you, Joey.
And just like a video of like,
yo, so this is how I've
been thinking about my shit.
- Okay.
- Like you could break the fourth wall.
Like, you could do it all,
you're in fuckin' control.
- Okay, that makes sense.
- Beauty.
- All right, perfect.
- All right my man.
- Thank you so much man.
Appreciate it.
- We're here to give tactics.
Give real fuckin' advice
on Tea with GaryVee.
It's mindset and it's fuckin' execution.
Clouds and dirt.
If you don't have both,
everybody's got fuckin' ideas,
nobody gives a duck about your idea.
Ideas are great
and they're the way the world turns,
but guess what?
If you don't execute on your ideas,
they're fuckin' dog shit.
People hide behind ideas,
because they don't wanna fuckin' execute,
because they're scared to
put themselves out there
because they're fear based,
'cause they're worried about
other people's judgements.
And people literally don't
fuckin' live their lives
based on other people's opinions.
And I've been put on the fuckin' earth
to suffocate the fuck
out of that conversation.
Hey Jess.
- Hi Gary.
How are you?
- I'm extremely well.
- I'm great.
And I'm so thrilled,
because I don't even care if
you don't answer my question,
I have to tell you.
You may have given my daughter
some of the best advice
she needed as a teenager.
Because your were in
Minnesota a couple summers ago
and we came up to see you from Wisconsin.
And she was like 15 at the time,
and I was kinda hoping,
okay, maybe Gary will
inspire her with income
or something like that generating money.
And actually, you said to the audience,
so what are you gonna do?
Are you gonna give up on your happiness
because your too afraid of
having a tough conversation
with a mom, dad, grandparent?
So instead you're gonna do
what they want you to do,
instead of trying what you wanna try.
And she just like,
I can't even tell you.
She brings you up all the time.
We were listening to you this
week on Wednesday morning
while we were making breakfast.
And she's like,
Mom, when this thing's over,
can we please go see Gary again.
like, we need to go here,
I love that guy.
So, I hope you go out on the road again,
because we're gonna come
and find you somewhere.
- Thank you, Jess.
You don't even know how
nice that makes me feel.
- Yeah, it was seriously,
I don't think you can possibly understand
how important that message was
for her in her life right now.
- I love that.
- It's huge, so thank you.
What can I answer for you?
- Okay.
So I quit teaching about
just under two years
and decided to go all in on
my content writing business.
And got really really blessed.
Got some great retainer clients
and now,
in the past like nine to 10 months
I really started shifting
towards copywriting.
And I love it.
And I'm really trying to master the craft,
getting up early, practicing,
doing all that kinda stuff.
But now I'm seeing how I need to
not just rely on referrals
and word of mouth.
I need to start building an audience.
But then of course, coronavirus has hit
and I'm just kinda like,
I'm tryin' to master the craft,
I'm tryin' to get new clients going online
and I'm just kinda struggling with
what do I prioritize.
Where do I spend my time.
That kinda stuff
- I think you spend
your time on putting out
sample work, um,
engaging with people.
Starting a Facebook group
of small business owners
in the Minnesota suburb.
What I think most people don't understand,
is that business is human.
And it's about humanity and people.
And so I think the number one thing
that you really need to think about
is just building a community
and getting people to know you.
Like, you know, moms
dealing with this, you know,
in a Facebook group
and we get to know Sarah
in Cleveland through it.
And then when this is over or even later,
when we get into like, what do you do.
Like literally being the
kind of person online
that is really good at a cocktail party.
Where you're not handing out
your business card to everybody
and trying to get everybody
to just do business with you.
You're just genuinely being human.
Talking about the weather,
talking about corona,
talking about sports,
talking about getting back to real life,
talking about kids and husbands
and just being a human.
And then inevitably in that conversation,
it comes around to,
by the way, what do you do?
And so, I think it's content
and community, right.
Putting out content.
What kind of content?
It could be a million things.
You making a video
of just way you decided
to get into copywriting
and just posting it out on
your Facebook and Instagram.
If 87 people watch it,
it begins the process
and then I think joining a ton of groups.
I think one of the great things
that people don't talk about
is virtual networking.
Starting up Google Hangouts and Zooms
and other things if that nature.
Just being the community leader.
Like literally posting on
your Facebook right now,
like, do 10 people wanna get, you know,
a happy hour with me tonight?
And just shoot this shit, you know.
And like, I'll send out
the Google Hangout link.
I think networking, just being a human,
is a huge factor.
- Great.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Take care, Jess.
- Take care.
- That was fun.
All right.
Dustin, get on here.
So everybody can see you right?
- Yup.
- Okay, I love that.
So Dust, couple things.
One, the comments that you've
been flashing down here
I love that.
- Okay.
- So we need to make
them sit there longer,
or when you hit flash,
that's how long they stay?
- No, they can sit for
a while, it's just, uh,
- I want to give people
the cloud and the exposure.
And it's dope, right?
- Yeah, I like it.
- You know, I would have loved it
if I was watching Randy
"The Macho Man" Savage
during their live, 20 years ago,
and he pinned my comment.
So, A, I wanna do that.
- Okay.
- B, a lot of people that are seeing
the comments in live stream are,
trying to figure out how this works so,
A, if you see people putting up questions
I don't mind you throwing that up,
not just nice comments.
- Okay.
- Like, utility questions,
not an actual question
because that's what the
people on the screen are for.
Team Gary, if you're
watching this right now,
which I know you are,
in Periscope, in YouTube,
a lot of places, a lot
of questions are like
what's the format?
How do I get on the show?
I'm gonna do a lot more community
management in the streams
helping people.
There's just a ton of questions,
so let's do that.
I like the rotation that
you're doing, you know,
over by you on the 'share this live'.
I think that's super fuckin' rad.
I like the phone number.
So I like a nice healthy mix.
I would say, 30 seconds on the comments.
You were doing about five before?
- Yeah.
It was just more of like me
just kinda experimenting, seeing--
- Yeah.
Let me go to the next question.
- Okay.
- Do five, 10, 15 and 20 second intervals
of just all comments while I'm on.
Let's see what that feels like.
- Cool.
- Awesome.
Let's keep this going.
- Okay, let's try it again.
- Yes.
We got it.
- You can hear me?
Oh my gosh, third time's the charm.
How's it going Gary?
How you doing?
How's your Sunday going?
- It's going well.
How are you?
- Good, good, good.
It's a little bit delayed,
but that's okay I'm--
We'll work with it.
- 100%.
What can I answer for you?
- So I am a wedding planner.
Perfect time to do that.
I'm also in the middle of construction,
which is where I am right now.
We were just scraping floors
so the flooring could come on Monday.
But my question is not for me,
it's actually for my entire community.
I live in a little town
called, Wisconsin Dells.
Woo-hoo, shout out to my town.
We are a tourism capital of the Mid-West.
Known for water parks,
big group conventions,
day trippers, overnight stays.
So right now we're taking a really big hit
because all of my friends,
everybody that I know,
they're either a owner
or they're employed by one.
So, I know social media
can be a really big help.
Matter of fact, the last
networking event that I attended
was a bunch of owners wondering,
how can they even get
started with social media.
And now they have plenty of time.
So my question for you is,
as a community,
what can we do to have a
campaign or something that can unify us,
because our customers are not here.
Our customers are in Chicago, Minnesota,
all over the States.
So what can we do right now,
so when this is all over,
we can have a recovery plan.
- It's about building awareness
to people that don't know about you.
And creating stickiness
with the people that do.
So, things that run through my mind
if I'm a water park in the area.
I'm thinking about,
obviously I'm worried about my employees,
I'm worried about myself.
But what can I do for the community.
Is there a donation I can do?
Is there something nice I can do?
Can I build up some
temporary testing sessions?
Like A, what can I do for the world?
B, the next thing I'm thinking about
is producing content around the stories.
The reality of our place.
So, I would immediately
go into story time.
Make three, four different videos about
how my grandfather started it.
You know, where we started it.
What was the first breakthrough.
The tough times.
The good times, the bad times.
Legitimately stories.
Then I would start doing also Zooms
and record them with the 25, 50 employees
or people in the community.
Record them just shooting the shit
and literally just take,
like in our own conversation,
telling everybody we're recording this
and we're gonna put it on YouTube.
Literally it's about creating content
to build awareness
of the area.
Because the reality is the core business
is not going to be a--
- I'm not hearing you but--
- Your not hearing me.
- No, I can't hear you anymore.
- I'm gonna give the answer
and then we're gonna move on.
So, the reality right now
during this time is to
tell stories.
To get people to know about your place.
And so, when your business,
when you're a restaurant right,
or a convention center
or anything effected so
aggressively by this,
a wedding planner, you know,
right now is a time to story
tell about you to the world.
This is the time to setup an
accounting on every platform
and create content, content, content,
so that people are aware
so when this is over
you have better chance of
getting some of it back.
Some things you just
can't navigate through.
They're just ironclad.
And right now what is ironclad
is people are not going
to large gatherings.
And so, if you look at
what the MBA's doing
they're thinking about
playing horse at home.
They're playing video game stuff.
It's just about creating
some kind of content
during this time.
- Okay.
So hopefully I can watch the live
so I can hear you.
But thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
- Bye-bye.
- I love this.
Big shout out to Susan Keely,
Seth Bieber, Carla Henders,
Hendrickson, excuse me.
All on Facebook right now.
I'm lovin' this.
Charles Clark, my man.
And YouTube community,
I appreciate you being here.
Marcus J. Carry.
What's good?
- What's up Gary.
How you doing?
- I'm well.
What's your name?
- Mike.
- Mike, real pleasure.
- Yeah, yeah.
I've been tryin' to talk to
you for the last year dude.
Glad I'm on.
- Made it.
Where you from?
- Yeah, yeah.
Made it, made it, yeah yeah.
Dude, my friend, Brad Smith,
he use to play for the Jets.
- Missouri, right?
All back in Missouri.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
At one point I was like,
yo, Brad, how can you get
me in a room with Gary.
- Number 16, he was a baller, man.
They were just a special team maniac
in 2009, -10.
Those runs was just
instrumental for success.
Big shout out to Brad Smith.
- Absolutely, yeah, yeah.
Brad and I go to the same church so,
I see him all the time.
- I'm glad.
- Yeah, yeah.
So here's my question.
So Gary, I am, um,
I'm an entrepreneur and I'm an educator,
so work at a school
that uses adaptive learning software
in place of direct instructions.
So there's no math teacher,
there's a math app, right, science app.
What that does is that
shortens the school day,
the academic portion
would be only two hours
and the rest of the day
is spent learning life skills
and doing like interest
based projects, right.
So we can do things that
nobody else can do like--
- Love it.
- I actually taught a workshop to kids
about how to flip sports
cards on eBay, right.
- Love it.
- So for six weeks
kids were like stealing
stuff from their parents,
flippin' it on eBay.
- Love it.
- The only like issue
with the model is that,
that right now, education like this
is not sustainable for
low income communities.
So I'm tryin' to figure out like,
what is a revenue model,
or like a profit mo--
some business model that you think
could make this accessible.
- How much does it cost?
- Right now, we're at $13,000 a year.
- Lost you, lost you.
- Oh, um.
Can you hear me now?
- Got you.
Go ahead.
- Right now, we're at $13,000 a year.
And then 24,000 for high school.
- (speaker's audio is cut off)
- I actually, I'm back.
I lost you.
- So, I mean, I can hear both of you, but
it's kinda strange.
- (speaker's audio is cut off)
- I can't hear you, but...
- Try again.
- (speaker's audio is cut off)
- I can hear like, it sounds weirded up.
- Yeah, well if the
live feed can hear you,
you just answer, I'll check the live feed.
- It might be the ones,
whoever has the kids in the background.
- That's me.
- Oh, okay.
'Cause if there's like
two different noises,
it kind of like cancels
the other person out.
- (speaker's audio is cut off)
- Um, barely.
Let me see what I can do.
Oops.
- One, two, one, two.
One, two, one, two.
- There you are.
- You can hear me?
- Yeah, yup.
- I can't hear you, Mike.
- Oh?
- New platform life.
Dustin, you can hear me?
- Yeah, I can hear both of you.
- Fuck, I can't hear--
(speaker's audio is cut off)
- Can you hear me now, Gary?
- (speaker's audio is cut off)
- Yeah, lost you.
- Yeah, I can only hear a little bit,
I can't really hear.
- Dustin.
Can you and Mike hear each other?
- Mike, can you hear me?
- Yeah, I can hear you.
- Yeah, I could hear Mike also.
- You guys can hear each other.
- Yeah.
- Of everybody here,
you two can hear each other
everybody can hear me,
but I can't hear shit?
- One second.
- All right, I'll hold on a minute.
(laughs)
This poor fuckin' dude.
Waited a whole year to speak to me
and it just got fucked up.
Dust.
Fuck.
Can you hear me Dust?
- Barely.
- Barely?
- So if you go on the bottom,
go to cam mic.
And then go to audio.
- I heard something.
I got you.
- Now I can hear you.
- Okay, beautiful.
Let's get Mike back on.
- All right, there we go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- We're back.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Okay.
So how much does it cost?
- So, 13,000 for k through eight.
And then, I think 24,000 for high school.
- Per year?
- Per year.
- All right.
So look, you've gotta go into
fundraising for scholarships.
You've gotta go into Corporate America
and see if Chase Bank or Sales Force,
you gotta fuckin' grind.
You gotta hit high net--
- Yeah.
- Net worth individuals.
And you gotta fuckin'--
People gettin' crunk in the background.
I love it, Mike.
- (laughs)
- You gotta go to high
net worth, if it's--
look, if you can't drive down the cost,
if you can't discount it to lower income,
then you need to figure
out how to go direct into
high net worth individuals
and organizations
and get scholarships.
Or, something that I think could work,
when I think about an app,
you can start thinking
things like Sysco and SAP
and Sales Force.
You see where I'm going?
All of a sudden I'm thinking, mm,
Marc Benioff's one of
the best dudes on earth
when it comes to
entrepreneuring, giving a fuck.
Is his company capable of
writing a $10 million check,
which goes ham for a fuck load of kids.
Subsidizing through
people who can afford it.
Around feeling good about themselves,
looking for the clout
or corporate objectives, real talk.
- Yeah, wow.
Okay, awesome.
That's awesome.
Thank you.
- Good luck.
- Thanks.
- Talk to you soon.
- Yeah.
- Can't wait to meet you,
in person.
All right, we're gonna be
rapping up here in a second.
Let's get, you got one
more for me, Dustin?
Ron or Williams, what's good?
- We got two in the queue.
- All right, let's bang
them out real fast.
- Okay.
- Hello.
- Hey Tom, where you from?
- Toronto.
- Very nice to meet you.
- You too.
So just a quick question.
So my parents, um,
they doctor, dentist,
they force me to go to dental school.
I'm in my third year, so I'm almost done.
So I can't really do--
- You fuckin' hate it.
- Yes, and I can't really
do anything about it
other than just finish right now.
- Yup.
- And yeah, so I really do hate it.
Each day, it's really
hard and whatnot so, um,
even when I graduate I'm not
sure if I actually want to,
actually be a dentist.
- You don't.
You don't.
Tom, listen to me.
Tom, there is no way on earth
that you can be a dentist.
You fuckin' hate it.
- Mm-hmm.
- You're gonna be 36 years old
and you're gonna resent your
parents for your whole life.
You're gonna resent them.
- Mm-hmm, yeah.
That's what I feel.
Which sucks, yeah.
- You already have underlying
resentment towards them.
- Mm-hmm, yes I do, yeah.
- You love your parents?
- Yes, yes I do.
And my mom, she wants me to
take over her dental practice
because she is a owner
of her own practice,
so yeah, there's that,
complication too, so.
- No.
- Yeah.
Tom, I won't let you.
I will go to Toronto and
put you out of business
and start my own dental practice,
if you do that.
- Okay.
- You can't do that.
Tom, you're gonna be sad.
- Yes, yeah I know.
I'm already very like sad.
It's like--
- Yup.
- It's like taking a--
- Can I help you?
- Mm-hmm.
- Okay, number one,
Tom, you're not gonna be a dentist.
- Mm-hmm.
- I promise you, you will not.
- Number two.
The next year and change of--
How long are you in dental school for?
- I have one more year,
but because of the
coronavirus, yeah, it may...
- You're gonna treat that year differently
than you've treated every other year.
You're gonna enjoy yourself,
and it's gonna be your last vacation.
- Mm-hmm.
- You're gonna treat it as a vacation.
You're gonna try to pass, of course,
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- but your not gonna stress as much
and you're gonna enjoy your downtime.
You're gonna study a little less
and you're gonna have more fun.
- Mm-hmm.
- And then you're gonna come out of school
and you're gonna tell your parents
you're not taking over
the dental practice.
And they will be upset.
- Mm-hmm.
- And mom will cry.
- Let me just get, hold on one second.
Mom will cry, she'll cry.
And dad or mom will be like
you're an idiot, your bad,
for 12 months,
for 24 months,
for 36 months.
But you can not be a dentist, Tom.
It's the most obvious thing
I've ever seen in my life.
You hate it.
- Mm-hmm.
Yes, yes, that's true.
Yeah, I was thinking like
what I could do after.
Like I really like filming, whatnot but...
- So move to California,
get a shitty job
and get into the game.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's
what I was thinking of doing.
Like that or like New York,
or something like that, yeah.
- That's right.
- Mm-hmm.
- Tom, listen to me.
Listen to me, because I don't believe
that you're gonna listen to me.
I'm gonna keep you on a little longer.
Listen to me.
- Mm-hmm.
- Upsetting your parents
for a short period of time,
so that you can have the love forever,
is much fun than making them fake happy
for a period of time
and then hating them forever.
- Mm-hmm.
Yes, yes, yeah, uh, yeah, I know you.
You said that on numerous times before and
I do understand but--
- Do you want me to come with you?
Do you want me to fly home with you
and when you tell your parents--
- No, no, no.
- I will come.
I will come with you.
And I will hold your hand
and we'll tell your parents
we're not fuckin' gonna become dentists.
- My parents know, I
already told them but--
- They're not listening.
- Yeah, exactly.
They immigrant parent.
They saying that I'm being unrealistic,
what else can I do and whatnot.
And that's what, yeah...
- I don't like it.
I don't like it.
They're being selfish, Tom.
They're doing the wrong thing.
They love you,
- Yes, yes.
- but they're being selfish.
- Mm-hmm.
- They're wrong.
- Tom, do you want me to come with you
and sit with your parents
and drink some tea and
tell them what's up?
- I think I'm okay though.
Thank you for the offer.
- Do you wanna FaceTime me in
when we start conversating.
And I'll sit there and give
them a piece of my mind?
- Uh, maybe some time in the future.
- Okay Tom.
Tom, listen to me.
We're obviously playing
around here a little bit.
I know this is difficult,
I know it's difficult.
But I promise on all my heart,
I promise,
- Mm-hmm.
- You can't become a dentist.
It will be the worst
decision of your life.
- Mm-hmm.
I was thinking maybe I
could do it like part time--
- No!
- No?
- No, no.
You're not gonna be a dentist.
- Okay.
- The only reason you're gonna do that,
is 'cause you love your parents.
- Yeah, mm-hmm.
- And you respect your parents.
- Mm-hmm.
- I'm telling you to your
beautiful young face,
you're gonna end up hating them
- Mm-hmm.
Okay.
- Do you wanna hate your parents?
- No, no I don't.
- That's right.
I know you don't.
So listen to me,
you're on the verge of hating them
because you're gonna blame them
and resent them your whole life.
I don't know if I've
ever seen somebody hate
something more than I've
seen you hate dentist.
- Mm-hmm.
- You fuckin' hate it.
- Mm-hmm, yes I do.
- I can feel it.
I have good chemicals like that.
You can't be a dentist.
- Mm-hmm, yes.
- You can't.
Not part time, not some
times, not over the summer.
Nothing.
- Mm-hmm.
- It's over.
Yes.
- Brother, you can't do it.
- Yes, yeah.
- Your parents will love you
and I'm gonna tell you
something very powerful,
very powerful.
- Mm-hmm.
- Your parents will respect
you more for not doing it,
than doing it.
- Mm-hmm.
- It doesn't feel like that now.
- Listen, I'm from immigrant parents,
I live in immigrant circles,
I know this isn't easy.
I know that Americans and
Canadians don't understand.
It's a different culture, I know.
- Mm-hmm.
- I know.
But I'm telling you right now,
I know so many 54 year old Toms
that are doctors, lawyers,
engineers and dentists,
and they are not in a good place.
They're alcoholics and drug users.
They have no relationship
with their parents.
And if it's not those three things,
they're just sad.
And that's the worst of
the fuckin' four of them.
- Mm-hmm.
Yeah, yeah, that's true.
- You have to have courage to do this.
- Yeah, yeah, I do.
- Two to three bad years,
two to three bad years,
and a lifetime of a good
relationship with your parents.
Versus a lifetime of
not a good relationship
with your parents.
- Mm-hmm.
- Your parents are scared.
They want you to be safe.
- Yup.
- They're over codling you.
Mamma's gonna give you the business.
It's gonna be okay.
You can get married and
I can have grandchildren.
She's being shit selfish.
- Mm-hmm.
Yes, yes, that is true.
- Tom, if I fuckin' find out
that you became a dentist,
I swear to fuckin' God,
I'm gonna go up to that dentistry
and I'm gonna cause fuckin' havoc.
- Yes, yes, thank you.
- Listen to me, Tom.
You know my phone number?
212-931-5--
you're in Canada, right?
I think it works in Canada,
I think it works in Canada.
Listen to me, listen to me.
Use me.
I do not believe that we accomplished
you not being a dentist here.
I think we're gonna hang up.
- Okay.
- And you're still gonna
be a part time dentist.
And I don't like that feeling right now.
- Mm-hmm.
Yes. (laughs)
- I don't want that for you, brother.
You're gonna resent them,
you're gonna be unhappy.
- Mm-hmm.
Yes, yeah that's what I'm afraid of, yeah.
- Do me a favor.
Re-watch this video everyday.
- Yup.
I will do.
- Start editing.
Start playing.
Start reaching out.
Start Dming people that
made contact in L.A.
- Mm-hmm.
- If you need help,
I know a lot of directors
and producers in L.A.
I will help you.
- Thank you.
- Tom, are you gonna
be a part time dentist?
- Um--
- Tell me the truth, Tom.
- I know that I need...
Initially I was thinking part time dentist
and then part time like exploring film
and my hobbies, you know,
my interests and whatnot.
So that's something to like
pay for the bills and whatnot,
but yeah,
I'm a bit unsure at the moment.
But I do agree with you.
I have thought about like
not becoming a dentist after
and just dropping it,
but then, um,
let's say my mind's all over the place,
sometime I will say,
be a part time dentist,
sometime I will say
just drop it completely
and pursue film
and, yeah, it's a bit...
And there's also parental
pressures and whatnot,
but yeah.
- Listen to me.
Money is not success,
happiness is success.
- Mm-hmm.
Yes.
- You have to, have to,
have to, have to, have to,
go to Los Angeles.
Get a shitty job in entertainment.
- Mm-hmm.
- Start networking in that world.
- I would be so proud of you
if you were a receptionist
or an assistant,
or an intern of the intern in Hollywood,
more than fuckin' getting
a job as a fuckin' dentist.
- Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
I know that...
This is more like, I know
because I'm Canadian and
due to Visa stuff,
I need like a job offer before.
- Good news,
good news, Tom.
Toronto and Vancouver film--
- Yes, exactly yeah.
- Filled, filled with fuckin' jobs.
- Yeah, Toronto has a lot, yeah.
- And Vancouver, and it's
fuckin' nice out there.
- Mm-hmm.
Yes, exactly.
- Where do your parents live?
- We live in Toronto,
or like the Toronto--
- Suburbs.
- Yeah.
- Okay, Tom,
you need to go to Vancouver.
- Mm-hmm.
Yes, like that escape from--
- You need to go to Vancouver.
- Mm-hmm.
Okay.
I will do that.
- Hold on one second.
Hey Brandon?
- [Brandon] Yeah?
- I'll call you right back on WineText.
I'm sitting here,
fixing Tom from Toronto's' life.
On live stream.
- [Brandon] Got it.
You got it.
- We're telling him not to be a--
Brandon, can you please tell
him not to be a dentist?
- [Brandon] Tom, don't be a dentist.
- Did you just hear that?
Tom, this is my best friend, Brandon.
Who's known me since--
Brandon, you've known me since I was 14.
Tell Tom how often I'm right.
- [Brandon] He's pretty much
right, 99.8% of the time.
Usually more actually.
- And Tom, this is not
the 0.2% of the time.
I love you Brandon.
I'll call you back.
Tom.
- Yes.
- You're going to Vancouver,
and you're schlepping around lighting
or doing some dog shit thing
and your gonna be the
happiest fucker ever.
- Mm-hmm.
- Or you're gonna stay in Toronto
and fuckin' be miserable.
- Mm-hmm.
Yes, thank you.
- You're welcome, Tom.
Fuck, I think everybody
just fell in love with Tom.
(exhales)
Man.
That was int--
(horse blows)
(sigh)
I mean Blake,
how the fuck are you gonna follow that?
- I know, right.
Except, you know, we tried to
push our kids to be dentists,
but they didn't though.
- (laughing)
Are you joking?
Or please tell me that's the truth.
- Yeah, that's the truth, yeah.
- Oh my God, Blake.
That's fuckin' amazing.
Oh, I love this shit.
Did you hear my rant Mom?
The next guy on,
goes, we tried to push
our kids to be dentists.
- (laughs)
- That's awesome, Blake.
But they didn't listen to you.
- No, they didn't listen.
We didn't push too hard,
but my wife had a lot--
- I respect that.
- Had a lot of clients who were dentists
and we're like, yeah,
these guys are killin' it.
And so we're thinking,
we want our kids to be
dentists, you know, but--
- I respect that.
I get it, I get it.
How are you?
What can I help you with?
- Well man.
We're in a--
I started my company in 2013.
We're a home inspection company
and we've grown to 39 employees.
And we're just killin' every year.
First quarter, we were
up 54% year over year
and of course now, with this lockdown,
everything's just gone to shit.
We can still work,
but you know,
people are just not buying houses.
They're sittin' on the side lines.
- Of course.
- And so we pivoted--
What was that?
- I said, of course.
That makes sense.
- So we kind of pivoted,
so we did some research
and we came up with a
decontamination service,
where we can go in and
decontaminate houses
before people move in and so that's,
that's helping to bring in
a little bit of revenue.
But now I'm just tryin'
to grab market share.
And I love your mindset
of abundance and, um,
you know, we try to keep that.
But we're just tryin to
figure out the best way
to grab market share now,
even though it's not
gonna generate revenue.
So, 90% of our referrals
come from realtors.
So that's who we work with.
So I just wanted to get
your thoughts on that.
- Where is your business?
Where are you based?
- We're in Dallas-Fort Worth and Austin.
- I love it.
So I would start a small business
or even a real estate
Facebook group immediately.
I would post on all your social networks,
whether personal, for the business,
that you're hosting Zoom
and Google Hangout sessions
every night, happy hours.
To have businesses--
Become the host of the party
of the discussion
in real estate agents, insurance brokers,
you know, banks, entrepreneurs.
Become the mayor of your town, virtually.
Become the Pied Piper that's hosts
virtual happy hours and
parties every night.
People will become aware of you.
It's networking.
There's 50 people on the
screen just talkin' shit,
your the fuckin' head of the table.
Okay Rick, what do you got?
Where you from?
Become the Pied Piper.
Become the host every night, Blake.
I'm not kidding.
Immediately.
This Monday, 7:00 pm
on this link on Google,
I'm hosting a party for
all real estate agents
you know, construction,
you know, developers.
We're just gonna shoot
this shit for Dallas area.
You know, real estate professionals.
Bring your bottle of wine,
bring a beer,
bring a cocktail,
bring a coffee.
We're gonna just shoot the fuckin' shit.
And that to me--
I guess Blake didn't like the advice.
Blake, you didn't like that?
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
Blake?
- He's still there, but
I'm not sure what's happened.
- I'm sorry.
- That's okay, Blake.
- Sorry.
Yeah.
- No worries, brother.
- No, that's sounds awesome.
- Become the host of the party.
It will work, it will work.
Because you're gonna build awareness.
- Yeah, we've done some Zoom conferences,
but I hadn't thought about
just doing the Hangouts every night.
Yeah, that's awesome.
- Every night, you know,
seven to nine pm, you know,
Dallas or Texas, name it.
Texas real estate professionals,
you know, happy hours.
And just be the host
and make it invite only.
People have to hit you up and
you gotta approve them.
It could be a whole fuckin' thing.
Throw the party.
It's the high school party rule.
Whoever had the house to throw the party,
became cooler in high school.
Your way of becoming cooler, is that.
Do you understand?
- Gotcha, yeah.
- And you don't even need your parents
to go away for the weekend.
It's called fuckin'
Google Hangouts and Zoom.
- All right, man.
That's great, I appreciate it.
Talk to you soon.
Thank you.
All right, I'm getting out of here.
I really appreciate everybody.
YouTube, Facebook,
Periscope, Twitter, LinkedIn.
I appreciate all of you.
Dustin, get in here for a second.
- Oops.
Hold on a sec.
Hello.
- Pretty good format.
What were you seein'?
- A lot.
(laughs)
I was trying to keep
track of the comments,
but they're going by so fast that it's--
- Sure.
- Yeah.
And then at the same time
just having the people coming in.
- I don't see LinkedIn
comments on the comments.
- Let me take a look.
- Was it streaming on LinkedIn?
- It was, um.
Yeah, I don't see them coming in either.
So, I'll double check on that
after this stream's over.
- Okay.
Let's go into the Team Gary group
and let's figure this out.
- Cool.
- Anyway, thank you to
everybody watching tomorrow--
- Oh, shit.
- Tea with GaryVee.
Looking forward to it.
Set your RSVPs.
We'll put it out right
now on all our social.
Set your alarms.
Get in here with us tomorrow.
Tea with GaryVee,
9:00 am eastern,
6:00 am in the west coast,
get up.
Get up and get at it.
We'll see you tomorrow.
Love you, bye.